if you're a metal gear fan you're  probably in the club that thinks Hideo  Kojima should just make a movie already  well he's just responded to that request  I'm Tony and this is your cinematic  GameSpot news update Kojima spoke just  this weekend at the Tribeca games  festival  the short answer it's not happening soon  or maybe ever the long answer I love  movies so definitely one day I would  love to but right now it's impossible at  least until I finished at stranding it's  impossible I love films too much that  maybe if I start making a movie  I would never finish it speaking of  debts stranding that's coming to ps4 and  PC at some point in the future we got  our first glimpse of the mysterious game  at last year's e3 and with the next  convention just a few weeks away it's  possible Kojima may gray Sony stage  again we'll see but for more on a game  you'll definitely be playing this year  you can check out our lobby discussion  on Call of Duty World War 2  you  [Music]